simple public mission I guess that begs
the question what's regular my question
before you get to simple huh my question
and then sure enough there is stuff
called complex harmonic motions here's
the basic idea
maybe you want to do this definition
okay
the idea is about oscillation now maybe
that's just replacing another so we're
trying to put some more basic hundred
it's wherever you've got some object and
its movement is back and forth up and
down or something like that
okay so some examples right things that
move back and forth okay
a pendulum is that is the classic
example another good example would be
say a metronome
now these tend to be left right yeah
right what kinds of things are get up
and down I would say tie it's for
instance okay I would say a bouncing
ball if it's if it's bouncing off like
not like a medicine ball is it that is
not harmonically it's going up and down
back and forth oh it's changing
direction over and over again okay so
it's not just like all this one
stationary point or just a couple it is
just you know as many as you can based
on and however much force is applied
into the situation okay now I said we're
looking simple Hubble animation what's
complex how my permission
let's think about this bouncing ball
okay
everyone noticed that even if you have a
really really bouncy ball okay
that when you drop it from some fire
okay if we do quite versus time okay
it's not gonna come
the same height that it went that you
dropped it from alright it's not gonna
get quite so high it's gonna lose energy
throughout okay
now this kind of process of losing
energy is often called damping right so
this is complex motion in that it's it's
got other forces acting on I'm not just
this back and forth business in the same
way a pendulum right like a real
pendulum is just is actually got out of
air resistance on it right so if you
pull it and then you let it go
eventually it'll stop okay
so therefore many other metronome is a
good example because actually being
driven and it I mean that's the point of
it it's going to be rhythmic and it's
going to keep on going at a particular
frequency okay so here's the important
thing about
there are are two ways to define this
I'm gonna give you the visual intuitive
one first and then we'll have a look at
the algebraic one right let's draw our
sine curve just a regular old okay so
some things to know about this if that
object is moving and it's displacement
it follows something like the saenko
this kind of shape we call a sinusoidal
wave anyway which is very good sign from
if it's doing this that's what we call
super harmonic motion so some things to
know number one it's periodic right so
it's going to repeat regularly right
which is different from this
this is repeating but it's not repeating
regularly there's no period there's no
like every 2 pi I'm doing this ok um in
repeated motion but it gets more once
more so it's actually not periodic okay
secondly we have what's called a arm a
single equilibrium position
mouthful it's kind of misnomer because
equilibrium sounds like something you do
when you get yo you do yoga or something
and you're like doing this stay well
you're very still okay in simple
harmonic Misha the equilibrium precision
is the opposite of that it's that you're
moving the fastest at that point it's
your centre of motion okay because if
you can imagine this is you know some
polygon it's going up and down up and
down as it passes the origin right x
equals zero it's racing past at the
maximum speed that's the fastest it can
go okay so the important thing is this
just one okay so later on for instance
we'll get to look at graphs which are
you know the sums of different kinds of
frequencies of sinusoidal waves so they
don't just have one crest and one
equilibrium position they'll do things
like this they'll go up here and then
they'll come down here and that kind of
thing okay this is probably tumbling
motion right it's got more than one
equally improvement position where it's
racing cost okay and lastly these
extremities
these exchanges are where the maximum
force is being applied to the object
okay so you can see at this point will
you stop right you're the furthest away
and so you're being pulled back the most
and that's why it stops and turns around
okay and that's why the you couldn't
position is called the equilibrium
position because at that particular
point there are no forces acting on it
okay in some senses that's where the
object is happy okay
so it's not being pushed one way or
another the reason why it's still moving
is because it has this momentum which
carries it until I get to push the
opposite way okay so there's kind of
what it looks like right now in terms of
a mathematical definition here's what
marks is the equation that marks simple
harmonic motion okay and it has to do
with what we've been looking at in terms
of acceleration and displacement
okay now acceleration force I told you
it is based on how far you are away from
this equilibrium position okay so this
is x equals zero the further you are
away the more force you have in the
opposite direction so if I'm really far
the positive direction
I'm being pushed in the negative
direction does that make sense and
that's why I turn around and if I'm in
the negative direction I'm getting
pushed in the positive direction so that
means acceleration has the opposite sign
of the displacement okay because if I'm
in the positive direction over here this
will be negative and if I'm taken here
this will be positive okay this is
rather neat we want to say you know this
might be bigger or wider
okay so we've sticky inside as I was
gonna write K we actually stick in a
constant here and squared okay and the
squared is just to make it positive okay
this is not just an equation it's called
a differential equation you might have
heard me I sort of say that word offhand
all it means is you're relating some
function to one or more on its
derivative
in this case is a function and its
second derivative okay so sometimes you
will say words like prove the
differential equation for this simple
harmonic motion or something like that
okay and this is what they referring to
it's it's big flowery language all that
means is there's a function there's its
derivative second derivative that's how
they relate to each other okay they're
proportional to each other that's it